et
si les gouvernements du monde entier
essayait de nous empoisonner en secret
en nous aspergent ans grâce à des avions
complot
[Musique]
bienvenue à bord de ce vol air complot à
destination de triangle des bermudes
pour votre sécurité peuvent y rester
assis à vos places lors de l'épandage
des chemtrails nous vous rappelons que
ce vol et non et éthicien et il est
strictement interdit de facto etc et les
informations sur internet l'esprit
critique doit être impérativement
éteints à bord de ce vol
les combats de francs maçons et les
peaux humaines de reptilien doivent être
placés dans les coffres prévu à cet
effet ou sous les sièges de banques en
cas de révélations de supercherie du
mouvement anti max un masque chirurgical
tombera automatiquement à votre portée
le nouvel ordre mondial vous remercie
d'avoir choisi un complot et vous
souhaite un agréable voyage
vous voyez les traînées blanches
laissées derrière les avions dans le
ciel des personnes affirment que
certaines de ces traînées contiendrait
des produits chimiques et des métaux
comme du baryum destiné à nous
empoisonner ou à me nuire de façon
générale il s'appelle c'est renier
maudite des chemtrails de l'anglais
chemical chimiques et trails chemin
selon les versions elle pourrait servir
à différentes choses pour contrôler la
circulation d'une part en rendant une
partie des gens stériles ou malades en
volant à 10000 mètres d'altitude faut
bien viser ans quand même pour rendre la
population plus obéissante en inhibant
sa capacité à se révolter on a bien vu
que ça marchait hyper bien surtout en
france d'autre part ça pourrait être une
façon de contrôler l'économie d'un pays
par exemple en balançant des poisons
pour saboter les récoltes et enfin ça
pourrait aussi servir à contrôler le
climat d'après cette version-là de la
théorie les chemtrails serait une
techniques de géo-ingénierie la
géo-ingénierie sera un vrai truc hein
c'est la science qui étudie comment
modifier artificiellement le climat
alors c'est souvent des projets un peu
farfelues comme pourraient le concevoir
un super méchant de marvel du genre
larguer des brouettes et de sulfate de
fer dans les océans pour faire pousser
les algues et qu'elle mange le co2 de
l'atmosphère oui c'est un vrai projet ou
encore faire pousser des nuages tout
là-haut là où dans la très haute
atmosphère pour renvoyer les rayons du
soleil vers l'espace comme un bouclier
et ainsi faire baisser la température
sur terre mais tout ça c'est des projets
en plus ou moins diable d'ailleurs rien
est encore fait et d'après certaines
personnes les kentridge pourrait
s'inscrire dans cette lignée on s'avance
justement de boucliers aux rayons du
soleil a priori cette théorie des
chemtrails il remonterait aux années
1990 et elle s'est développée comme
beaucoup d'autres théories du genre
grâce à internet attention spoiler les
scientifiques sont unanimes
personne n'essaye de vous droguez avec 7
rennais d'avion cette histoire de km 13
est une théorie du complot et oui désolé
de vous décevoir en 2016 des chercheurs
ont interrogé des scientifiques
spécialistes du genre de chimistes de
l'atmosphère météorologues tout ça et
99% d'entre eux ont trouvé aucune preuve
de l'existence de ces km 13 le 1%
restant est peut-être mort entre temps
ou alors il a été emprisonné par la cia
depuis j'ai pas trouvé plus d'infos là
dessus mais je vous le concède à la base
c'est pas complètement idiot le fait est
qu'on sait balancer des trucs depuis des
avions pour éteindre un incendie pour
répandre des pesticides sur un champ où
des herbicides pour détruire une forêt
dans laquelle nous et demi ce tas piste
je parle de l'agent orange que les
américains ont fait pleuvoir sur le
vietnam dans les années 60 et 70 donc
techniquement on sait faire mais en
volant bas là en l'occurrence on parle
d'avions de ligne de haute altitude et
c'est rennais qui zèbrent le ciel sont
en fait constitué d'eau et oui
techniquement c'est raide et sont même
des nuages créée par l'homme des cirrus
homogène hit us d'après l'atlas
international des nuages mais comment
ces traînées de condensation secret car
oui c'est leur vrai nom et bien tout
simplement grâce à la rencontre du feu
et de la glace ou plutôt de l'air très
chaud et humide qui sort des réacteurs
de l'avion et de l'air très froid de
l'atmosphère tout en haut là bas où tout
est calme tout et sauvage cette
rencontre va condensé de la vapeur d'eau
contenue à la fois dans l'atmosphère est
émise par les réacteurs d'avion cette
vapeur d'eau transparente donne aussi
des petites gouttes d'eau liquide puis
des cristaux de glace qui eux pour le
coup sont visibles et paf ça fait un
nuage qui voguera entre une seconde et
plusieurs heures dans le ciel vous
remarquerez que cette réaction est pas
instantanée et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
toujours un petit espace entre un avion
et le début des traînées de condensation
derrière lui et la formation de ces
traînées dépend de plein de choses de
l'attitude de l'avion faut que ce soit
entre 8 et 12 km de la quantité de
vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère du type
de carburant qui l'utilisent bref tous
les avions ne l'as pas systématiquement
de traîner derrière or donc les
complotistes reproche assez chemtrails
c'était très mis délibérément pour nous
faire du mal analysons cette phrase
voulez-vous délibérément non c'est juste
un effet du fonctionnement de l'avion on
ne fait pas exprès de les maîtres
ensuite pour nous faire du mal c'est à
dire que d'après les adeptes de cette
théorie les chemtrails il contiendrait
des métaux comme de l'aluminium du
baryum et d'autres particules
susceptibles de provoquer des problèmes
respiratoires et même parfois
d'entraîner des maladies comme alzheimer
ou parkinson
analysons cette très longue phrase les
traînées d'avions contiennent des
machins et bien oui effectivement les
avions l'âge des cochonneries dans le
ciel alors pas de baryum n'est rien de
ce genre en tout cas j'ai pas trouvé de
sources allant dans ce sens mais plein
d'autres trucs sympathiques les avions
de las derrière des aérosols et des suis
issu de la combustion de le récent du
kérosène un peu comme les gaz
d'échappement des voitures qui sont
rarement très propre et bien là c'est
pareil c'est cracra encore une fois
c'est pas fait intentionnellement c'est
comme dire que vous prenez votre voiture
spécifiquement pour polluer ou pour
filer de l'asthme à vos voisins j'ose
espérer que c'est pas le cas quand même
sinon c'est que vous n'êtes plus plus
américain que je ne le pensais et
d'autre part ces polluants émis tout
là-haut là-haut à une dizaine de
kilomètres d'altitude ne touche pas le
sol il se dilue dans l'atmosphère donc
pour reprendre la suite de la phrase les
traînées provoquerait des maladies et
banon elles n'ont juste pas d'impact
direct sur la santé humaine mais c'est
pas pour autant que les avions sont tout
beau tout propre évidemment les zones
proches des gros aéroports peuvent
prendre très cher côté pollution de
l'air heureusement c'est surveillé et
ses fameux gaz d'échappement des avions
contiennent des ingrédients pas jojo du
type co2 aux hommes tout ce qui est bon
pour réchauffer le climat ça me faut
savoir que les avions contribuer au
moins à hauteur de 3 5% au changement
climatique actuel c'est loin d'être
négligeable et figurez vous que les
traînées de condensation et contribue
aussi un tout petit peu à force du
passage des avions ça peut créer un vrai
petit voile nuageux dans le ciel et ça
peut augmenter un peu l'effet de serre
en emprisonnant les rayons du soleil sur
terre au lieu de les laisser repartir
vers l'espace des chercheurs ont calculé
qu aux etats unis ces nuages artificiels
aurait contribué à augmenter la
température de 0 2 degré tous les dix
ans ironiquement oui c'est traînées de
condensation influe donc bien sur le
climat mais beaucoup moins que les gaz
d'échappement des avions et encore une
fois je doute que ce soit prémédité
c'est juste une conséquence du trafic
aérien en vol est pour reprendre une
conclusion de l'article d'un
météorologue qui m'a bien servi pour mes
recherches outre le fait qu'il est peu
crédible que des épandages en altitude
et lieux ils ne sont nullement
nécessaire pour expliquer les traînées
de condensation qu'on voit aujourd'hui
dans le ciel et s'il n'y a pas besoin de
cette théorie pour comprendre ce qu'on
observe c'est peut-être juste qu'elle
est fausse
[Musique]